after more than a year without a
parliament voters are lining up for
hours in guinea-bissau to elect a new
one nearly a million people are
registered to vote with hopes this time
they'll be changed
we have been in crisis for four years
prices of basic necessities have risen
taxes have risen significantly
more than 20 political parties are
contesting 100 seats in Parliament after
president
Umar sissoko imbalo dissolved it last
May accusing some MPS of corruption and
that was a few months after an attempted
coup Friday marked the last day of
campaigning with thousands showing up to
a rally in support of the two main
political parties president imbalo has
been criticized for seeking to change
the Constitution and expand his grip on
power Guinea pissau's political system
allows the majority party or coalition
to appoint the government but the
president can dismiss it in some
instances this has led to political
infighting and Division in the past
people say they want candidates who will
prioritize their needs
whoever wins must put the people first
he must not be in charge to take
advantage of the people but must work so
the people can benefit
has faced years of political and
economic turmoil food prices have gone
up and many are struggling to earn a
the future Prime Minister must focus on
education and health that has to be a
priority he must also Fight Hunger
because people are tired
we want peace and Tranquility we also
want our cashew nuts to be bought and
our children to go to school
it's unclear if one party will emerge
with an outright majority but voters
here hope their new lawmakers will bring
about changes that will improve their
lives Muhammad Al Jazeera
authorities in Senegal have cut access
to mobile